message to public is you know we we miss
our baby boy
and if he's watching you know mommy and
daddy loves you and we hope you get home
soon and safely
um to the public just you know share our
posts on facebook share the news reports
and try to get the word
out and his picture around and keep on a
lookout to be able to find
you know where he is and to be able to
bring him home back safe and sound
my mom got attacked by a dog and it
chewed her
tendon in her her ankles so she had to
have two hours of surgery and over 60
stitches so she
was crippled not able to walk so i left
on friday to go
to help take care of her and i had only
been gone four days before i woke up to
a phone call saying my son was gone
and when i found that out i hopped in
the car and
drove two and a half hours to get to the
airport since it's a small little
country city
and hopped on the next plane and landed
in vegas around 2 30 and
then that's when the search was able to
happen i had called police
at seven in the morning to be able to
report him as the
missing child and the responders came
out and
one called and spoke to me over the
phone the other talked to my boyfriend
about the situation of what happened and
it was a they had a misunderstanding and
canceled the
search and so my son was missing for
eight hours with nobody looking for him
and then when i came in town and they
were finally able to speak to me is when
they finally were able to report him as
missing
and they've searched everything and
trying to do what they can we just wish
it was
you know a little bit more from my
knowledge
i was already notified that somebody
would be coming over
but um
i didn't think when i didn't know when i
didn't
expect when and then when somebody did
come
they notified themselves as
my girlfriend baby daddy's sister
and they said they was here to pick up
more and
notified me that it was already
pre-arranged so
from my understanding from already been
told by my girlfriend that
somebody would be over i wasn't told who
i wasn't told when but i still had that
in the back of my mind so when that
person knocked on the door that's what
my
mind recommended right back to
so that's who i thought was gonna pick
up amari and as i'm
finna call my girlfriend and pack his
bag at the same time
she says that they already got
everything that they need for him and
i don't need to pack anything he he'd be
fine and she
regulated and she proceeded out the door
and as i'm on the phone trying to call
my girlfriend and i
that my last look of her it was just
walking down the stairs
so i closed the door and i started
calling my girlfriend over and over
until she answered the phone and
asked her was anybody supposed to
come that day to pick up more and she
said no
i said the lady just came to the door
says that she's
her baby daddy's sister and they just
picked up a warrant
and she started freaking out that's when
i ran out the door
and immediately start combing the area
looking around see what i can end
i see nothing bring your son back
wherever you wherever you at bringing
back
like immediately it's disgusting i mean
he's a helpless
two-year-old he's tiny and can't fight
back he doesn't know where he's at
doesn't know where mommy and daddy are
because we're the only two people that
he knows
and he he needs medicine
he you know he's scared he doesn't know
who these people are
and we just ask to bring him back safe
and sound because he doesn't deserve
this this is not okay
and it's what's what's really sickening
is that people
is making assumptions thinking that
i have to something to do with it that i
have heard
manipulated in some way which
that's sticking to me also because
you love us i mean we we never do
nothing like that
apparently not now because we were just
waiting
hoping something pops into the air
someone slips up and he's able to return
home right now so we're gonna
try to uh plan out a um a starter party
for him see how that works how we're
gonna
do the best we can and do whatever we
can to find them we're going to create
the search party on facebook and a
facebook event that's going to be public
and we
try to advise anyone who's free not
doing anything to come out and try to
help us find him
come through the city see if he's
anywhere in sight
we have a few ideas where he could be
and
the police are just saying that it's an
ongoing investigation so they're not
able to share much and we can't
you know share all the details either
because it's still ongoing and we
were you know don't want to interrupt
the process of trying to find him
and so we're just waiting and trying to
figure this out on our own as well
thank you guys thank